ok bah on est prêt moi moche et méchant
la quête bonne nuit edith bonne nuit
margot bon jeu gronde qui envoie des
textos acquis heureux parce que le 2 est
plus fort que l'on tu vas être avis pire
et toulouse reprend du service
c'était un tien du mois heures je peux
réussir le 2 d'aller encore plus loin
tiens et si drôle plus efficace et a
laissé sa chance et a dû tout sauf si
c'est agaçant c'est un garçon oui à quoi
il a une partenaire maintenant gros
méchant gru pourquoi le judogi agents du
sis wild de la vl ton m'a dit que sa
lettre audrey lamy
mais vraiment l'impression que le
personnage avait été créé pour elle déjà
j'avais vu le premier que j'en ai trouvé
absolument génial vous allez devoir
accompli
non désolé plus jeunes
j'ai trouvé des mariages pour qu'elle me
ressemble à un petit peu au niveau de la
frange la plus de cheveux et du côté un
peu pepsi drôle voilà hyper hyper
mignonne quoi vous ne devriez pas
annoncé à l'as vence le gendarme que
vous allez utiliser
tenez je monte elle est agent depuis pas
très très longtemps et on sent que l
aime tous les petits gadgets qui
s'amassent voilà c'est une vraie une
braise james bond girl
et voilà qui va y avoir des petites
choses avec groulx et ça je vous dévoile
pas tout je vous laisse un petit peu de
mystère peut se lâcher dans les
expressions dans les intonations ce cas
c'est la voix enfin voila c'est toutes
ces petites choses qui m'ont amusé à
faire j'ai l'impression d'avoir 14 ans
comme moi j'ai passé deux jours à jouer
dans la chambre avec les chiots à l'as
des as biya mais les gosses à une
première comme ça c'est excitant et je
me suis vraiment amusée je suis
propriétaire du restaurant salsa y salsa
qui est juste en face à limoges c'est
une caricature de monde mais attention
décorer avec le drapeau mexicain il
ressemble un peu à ce que dites vous de
ça el macho déjà le personnage lui-même
dans son dessin dans son invention il
est truculent cette fois je vous quitte
au fur et à mesure qu'on avance et quand
le personnage j'ai toujours georges roy
disney puis j'ai l'impression que
c'était moi
allez bonne journée et passait me rendre
visite je crois qu'il me ressemble
vraiment ou alors c'est moi qui donne
une complètement fou quoi tu vas
vraiment sauver le monde
ouais le monde entier
repas
oui et non
madame on me dit des choses qu'on me
disait pas pour le 1 je pense qu'il est
plus fort en tout cas le film il ya
plein de petites surprises dans le dans
le scénario et on se laisse porter
finalement par par l'histoire et ce qu'a
fait en tout cas le succès du moment
chez méchant hein c'est que les enfants
les parents on y va enfin nous quoi on
peut y aller